[Music]
if you're a Potter head you have
probably read the Harry Potter book
several times and realize that the
characters in the books don't really
look like those we saw in the movies but
we are happy to see that some artists
recreated our favorite characters so
they could look just like JK Rowling
imagines them make sure you watch this
video until the end to see why the Harry
Potter fandom thinks that book Ginny is
much better than movie Ginny if you love
Harry Potter as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you how the cast of Harry Potter
should have really looked Harry Potter
in the book the Boy Who Lived is
described as small and skinny for his
age
he had a thin face na Bellini black hair
and bright green eyes he also wore round
glasses together with a lot of scotch
tape and we can't forget the scar on his
forehead that was shaped like a bolt of
lightning we were really happy to see
daniel radcliffe's
play Harry Potter in the movie but he
was not perfect he could have been
skinnier and his hair could have been
darker but the most important thing that
was missing was probably his bright
green eyes Hermione's ringer the only
thing we know about her in the books is
that she had a bossy sort of voice lots
of bushy hair and rather large front
teeth it was very important because in
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire she
became more beautiful than she ever was
before her hair was no longer bushy but
sleek and shiny the reduction in the
size of her front teeth after a spell
that went wrong was also more noticeable
than ever
however and the watson was really
beautiful in all the Harry Potter movies
without the large front teeth so we
didn't really notice the difference in
the fourth movie Ronald Weasley and
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
Ron is described as tall thin
and gangly with freckles big hands and
feet and a long nose this is part of the
reason why some people thought that
Dumbledore was actually a time-traveling
Dumbledore as they had a similar
physical description but we know that it
doesn't make sense
anyway in the movies Ron is memorable
for his bright red hair he's also tall
but not exactly gangly he is also
missing the freckles and the long nose
but we don't really care about this as
long as he is played by Rupert Grint
Rubeus Hagrid and here is our favorite
Giants who will always be remembered for
telling Harry that he is a wizard and
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
he was described as a giant who is
almost twice as tall as a normal man and
at least five times as wide long tangles
of bushy black hair and a beard hid most
of his face he had hands the size of
trashcan lids and his feet in the
leather boots were like baby dolphins
even though robbie coltrane could never
be as big as this we think that he was
realistically the best Hagrid we could
ever find Fred and George Weasley the
twins have always been part of the
funniest duo in the movie
JK Rowling warning us to remember them
as the two pranksters because she
thought that their personality was more
important than their looks that's why
the only thing we know about them in the
books is that they didn't only have
freckles and red hair they were also
shorter and stockier than percy and ron
who were both long and lanky even though
the twins are taller than what the
writer imagined we think that it's
better this way and it's also really
weird to see James and Oliver Phelps
with a different hair color in other
movies Lily Evans if there is one thing
that we remember about Lily Evans it is
that harry had his mother's eyes as she
passed away before the beginning of the
movie she is nothing but a memory and
that doesn't keep many people from
remembering her as a woman that they
will always love she didn't only have
dark red hair
Lily was mostly known for her brilliant
green and almond-shaped eyes just like
Harry was supposed to be however just
like Daniel Radcliffe the actress who
played the young Lily doesn't have green
eyes it even inspired many memes on the
Internet and we think that it's really
funny Dudley Dursley we don't care about
how he looks his personality is always
going to make him ugly
according to her
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone he
had a large pink face
not much snacks small watery blue eyes
and thick blond hair that lays smoothly
on his thick fat head and Petunia said
that he looks like a baby angel but
Harry thought that he looks like a pig
in a wig in the movie Dudley has brown
hair instead of blond hair and while he
doesn't totally look like a pig
it is really his personality that lets
us know that he is the best Dudley
Baltimore fear of a name increases fear
of the thing itself this is why we
aren't shy to call him Voldemort however
we are still not really comfortable with
his looks in the book the Dark Lord was
tall and skeletally thin with a face
brighter than a school with wide livid
scarlet eyes and nose that was as flat
as a snake's with splits for nostrils
he also had hands large like pale
spiders we think that they nailed the
snake look in the movie but it would
have been interesting to see him with
red eyes rather than blue eyes it's also
fun to see the actor with a nose before
the special effects Draco Malfoy and
here comes our favorite bad boy if you
read the books you know that did Draco
actually first met Harry in Madam
Malkin's robes for all occasions on
Diagon Alley
he made a rather intolerant speech about
a muggle-borns even though he was
friendly towards Harry
he was also described as a boy with
white blond hair and a pale pointed face
we all have to agree that no actor would
have been better than tom Felton in the
role of Draco Malfoy mostly when it
comes to his personality and it's still
surprising to see how nice the young
actor is in real life Fleur Delacour we
don't know a lot about flora Delacour
except the fact that the young witch who
studied at Bo Bhutan's was extremely
beautiful but Ginny also thought that
she turned out to be really annoying
when she was dating her brother even
though the family finally accepted her
in the book we knew that flora had wavy
silver blond hair that seemed to float
behind her the actress who plays flora
is blond but her hair is tied in a bun
under her hat no matter what we wish
that we had a chance to get to know her
more in the movies because this young
woman totally deserves our attention
Severus Snape we thought that the worst
teacher in school would have gotten
tension and how we found out about all
the things he did for Harry in the books
he was described as having greasy black
hair a hooked nose and shallow skin it's
not a surprise as so many people thought
that he was a vampire and Alan Rickman
did have greasy black hair I know is
that could have been more hooked and it
looks pretty shallow however he was
supposed to be 31 years old at the
beginning of the movie but the beloved
actor was actually in his mid-50s at the
time making him much older than Lillie
Dolores Umbridge actually she is the
worst thing that ever happened to
Hogwarts there was no doubt that Dolores
Umbridge was going to be an evil being
as soon as we took a look at her in the
books Harry thought that she looks like
a large pale toad she was rather squat
with a broad flabby face as little neck
as Uncle Vernon and a very wide slack
mouth even the little black velvet bow
perched on top of her short curly hair
put Harry in mind of a large fly she was
about to catch with a sticky tongue even
though he hated this character we have
to admit that the actress in the movie
looks much better than that Sirius Black
here's a man that we hated that we love
and that we cried for after 12 years in
Azkaban it's not a surprise that he
looks terrible as we can read in the
books a mass of filthy matted hair hung
to his elbows if eyes hadn't been
shining out of the deep dark sockets he
might have been a corpse he also had a
waxy skin stretched over the bones of
his face that made him look like a skull
and yellow teeth Gary Oldman was too
handsome to portray a man that was so
disgusting and one little problem was
that the actor was in his mid-40s
even though Sirius was supposed to be in
his early 30s Remus Lupin and here comes
his friend Mooney unfortunately with his
condition it was a little hard to have a
normal life
and be accepted in society this is
probably why Remus was wearing an
extremely shabby set of wizard robes
that he had dined in several places
he looked ill and exhausted though quite
young his light brown hair was flecked
with gray
once again the actor looked much better
than the character in the book we
wouldn't imagine anyone else playing
this role but we have to admit that it
would have been interesting to see him
with shabby Wizards robes Albus
Dumbledore everyone loves Dumbledore
this is probably why he is Dickie
Roland's favorite character in the books
he wore half moon glasses had a long
crooked nose and flowing silver hair
beard and moustache it was enough for us
to imagine the best school principal in
the world if you are wondering what he
would have looked like when he was young
you'll have to watch the second
fantastic beasts movie in the Harry
Potter movie series Albus Dumbledore was
portrayed by two actors but many people
will agree that Richard Harris was the
best Dumbledore because he literally
looked like the popular character
Minerva McGonagall even though many
students don't like how strict she was
we have to admit that she was one of the
best teachers now that we are grownups
and we think that her looks reflected
her personality Minerva had hair that
was black pulled back into a bun square
glasses and beady eyes in the movies she
looked a little bit older than what we
thought she was but the actress was so
good that we quickly forgot the
description in the book and fell in love
with her if you want to know more about
her class you'll have to read short
stories from Hogwarts Luna Lovegood if
you were sorted in ravenclaw Luna is
probably one of your favourite
characters she was also very pretty
according to the books she had straggly
waist length dirty blonde hair very pale
eyebrows and retrouver ins eyes that
gave her a permanently surprised look
Evanna Lynch is pretty close to the
description in the movie even though her
hair is Taylor and not quite as straggly
she is pretty much perfect people even
say that Ivana is not playing Luna she
is Luna
said that she was her favorite character
when she was reading the books and
getting the role was a dream come true
neville longbottom we don't know why but
many people ended up with Neville even
though they both marry different people
anyway Neville was so clumsy that he
thought that he didn't even belong in
ravenclaw that isn't le turned out to be
the other chosen one and destroyed the
last Horcrux in the books Neville was a
round-faced boy and Rowling also stated
that she imagined him as a short plump
and blond boy at the beginning of the
movies Neville was not blond but he did
have a round face however he grew up to
be quite tall and not very plump we also
have to admit that the actor looks more
handsome than ever
lavender brown in the movies we don't
know a lot about lavender brown because
once again rolling thus the personality
of the character was more important and
she certainly caught our attention when
she was dating Ron but one thing is sure
the characters didn't change drastically
in the books compared to what we saw in
the movies in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban she was played by
Jennifer Smith before she was replaced
by Jessica cave in the last movies we
understand that the first actress was
maybe not ready for a big role for why
do they replace her with a white girl
instead of a black girl that could have
looked like her Ginny Weasley most
Potterheads agree that book Jennie was
much better than movie Ginny in the
books she had a long mane of red hair
and Bonnie right fits the description
however many fans were disappointed by
her personality in the books she was
much more confident and did many more
things than just waiting around for
Harry to come back this is why we fell
in love with her and you should read the
books if you want her to be your
favorite character too so which of these
characters was your favorite don't be
shy in the comment section down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for how the cast of Harry
Potter should have really looked for
more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 Harry Potter characters that
could be back in fantastic beasts thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]